hi i'm ross butler hey i'm lana condor
i'm noah centeno
hey guys it's anna hey it's madeline
it's janelle
and we are the cast of to all the boys
always and forever
and we're here with buzzfeed today to
play a game of who's who
here's the first one who's most likely
to get a little teary-eyed on the last
day of shooting
it's true i just it gets me every time
janelle
okay fine i'll take it i'm definitely a
crybaby
you cried during the wedding so you
can't we're never gonna forget that
who's the best at doing impressions of
other cast members
noah lana i only went with lana because
she spends the most time with everyone
that i feel like
she would have intel but i can
definitely
like hear noah no one can do funny kind
of impressions of people
lana was really good at playing lee and
margo lana
i wouldn't say they're good but
she's most likely to do the impressions
yeah and she
captures the essence like the character
essence of
each of us who's likely to laugh during
an awkward situation
lana me i would have said lana you think
me
yeah well because and i say that because
lana and i have like
really awkward situations a lot and she
doesn't laugh like we
ross and i have a really hard time
communicating
let's do 10 second role play action hey
what's up
uh good how are you
i'm going to craft you out i'm going to
get coffee do you want to
you don't have to if you don't want to
like yeah um
no i'm fine thank you i i have to go to
the bathroom
myself now or me yeah i might say
madeline
i find the humor in everything you
always have to find it
reason why is i said me and lana is that
both of us when we start laughing we
can't stop like that it's
contagious right there's no there's no
stop there's no going back once it
begins it's just
it's just rolling and yeah domino effect
who's the best at giving
relationship advice alana look at
us oh look at us look at us go
i think okay let me first hand i have
received
advice about this kind of thing from
like
the whole cast they're just like
different perspectives which is why it
works when he got everyone but
i don't know i feel like janelle is like
the wise old grandma so i always
i always go with that i love it yeah i
was thinking lana probably because she's
the person i would talk to you the most
about relationship advice and she can be
very sage about it i said anna because
even though she's the youngest she's
probably the wisest out of all of us
lana noah did you even say anything i'm
just offended
noah here's the thing about your
relationship advice is i think you can
i well i think you give good
relationship advice here it goes there
it comes
the levy's breaking ross i i think noah
gives good
love advice not relation advice you give
like a philosophical
like what is love what is love what
you're saying is i just confuse you
more you always are like well
i do feel like the core values of love
could be in your blood let me ask you
have you read osho
yeah that's his exactly you're right
it's lana every time every day who's
most like there to all the boys i've
loved before character
ross yeah ross i don't think i was
really acting for a lot of the
the movie i think it was it was just
kind of us
you're very cunning and your wit is so
just sharp and smart
it was rarely something written that
would come out of
trevor's mouth it was always like ross
sitting there like
like on the side for like 20 minutes
just like reeling and coming up with
different ways to say it
janelle what no because
i would get kind and you're so kind and
like genuine
i don't know i don't really think lana
is like largine or you're like margot
i don't really think you guys are like
your characters i was going to say ross
i don't know i don't know ross very well
even but like i can totally get trevor
vibes i'm like
yeah now that you've that anna not to be
annoying i think i'll change my answer
too
the way that she's very romantic and
like can be silly
so i've never met ross i've never had a
sweet
pain with ross who's least like there to
all the boy's character
madeleine or me i said you anna
oh because you're so like loving and
nurturing and warm and
kitty can be those things but she's like
sarcastic
and snarky and like you're just the most
lovely human
i'm definitely more sensitive than her
for sure come on chris though
chris and madeline i feel like very
different we're all so very different i
feel like it's kind of similar to you
and kitty
in the way that kitty and chris can both
be more sarcastic
than we are and we're like you know what
i mean they're both like
yeah you're both little love funks
but no it's it's like peter's this
brooding
kind kinda oh what am i gonna do with my
life
and noah is like let's do it i don't
care what happens
yeah he's very conservative who's most
likely to be caught taking a selfie
jenny han
and me
are you taking in a very stylish way
like you have a good aesthetic when it
comes to things thank you so much
who's most likely to break out into song
janelle now yeah because she is a singer
one day on set i was like feeling down i
don't even know why i was sick really
tired
and janelle was like anna every half
hour i will perform you a song
and it was one of the best days ever it
really she just turned that front upside
down
i was like i think it's time that she
was like ah six seven eight and would
you start
next time i see you i will also sing you
songs sing me a song
thank you yeah
100 you will just like explode out of
nowhere
into song and into trumpet and i feel
like it's like it's like your body being
like i need to get this energy out
and the thing is it's not even songs
that are relevant like
you'll sing a song from like the
hercules disney soundtrack
i will find my way who's most likely to
send a meme in the cast group chat
i feel like lana likes her memes does
she
i don't think so do you like names lana
yeah i do
here's what i think i think that if we
had a group chat
i would be the one that started it and i
would start it with a meme
that's a sensible argument to be had and
maybe anna because she's like
the young one yeah where are you sorry
you too
she sends us videos and yeah she'll just
be like
saw this random video of something
completely unrelated to everything but
thought it was amazing
and it always makes our day and we
always appreciate it so i would
definitely say sorry
she's she's just the best i'm trying to
make everyone smile who's most likely to
learn a tick tock dance and perform it
flawlessly oh i know the answer a lot of
times
not that i would perform it flawlessly
but i've learned too many things about
dances that's my reasoning
you do love your peep talk dances and i
love it when you do it with your sister
it's so
cute they are really thinking lana cause
of the tick tock dances that she's done
to her music
yes those are so fun anthony yeah
they're so cute anna i'd say anna i i'm
not a tick tock guy
i i don't like tick tock dancing i feel
like you would you would do it really
well
i'm a savage oh
god i don't even know the lyrics
what is this is that the corvette one
corvette corvette
i don't know i just it's it's like oh i
like on a roller coaster
what it's just the soul leaving the body
who's most likely to introduce you to a
band musician you've never heard of ross
ross ross is pretty good at that here's
what i'll say noah's like for
newer music i'm with like older music
yeah that's true
that's true ross noah i was saying ross
because
he would bring his boombox or stereo
into the hair and makeup trailer to set
and he would play some music that i'd
never heard
he introduced me to this really good
band called lempe
just like on this radio he was playing
or something he said noah for the exact
same reason
one time we were in the hair makeup
trailer together and he hooked up his
phone
and he just started playing the best
music i was like oh my gosh who is this
who is this and he gave me so many
artists that i love now i mean
lana's giving me a lot of music
recommendations i think out of everyone
like i have a
closer music taste to her so we always
i'm like oh my god sir this is me please
send me your playlist
yeah noah definitely has a bunch that
i've never heard of before so it's
always cool
who's most likely to break character
during a take
shauna yes he just like
wanted to say something ridiculous or
silly
and just like he'd say it and it would
be so unexpected and we'd all just start
laughing i agree i'm gonna change mine
yeah i've been one over two john
lana lana oh okay yeah making you but
but really lana lana's broken a couple
times
that's i think i've broken with every
single
actor i think yeah
consistently which is you know not a
great testament to me
to my to me acting abilities i genuinely
love you guys
and i genuinely love the cast so when
there's
moments that i see a tiny bit of
your heart come through in your acting
it tickles me a lot of you pulls the
parachute sometimes is what happens
when lana cracks i feel like everybody
cracks because
when she cracks she just has like the
smile that's just so infectious so it's
like
you can't help but just be like god damn
it
i remember janelle in the first movie
was like
she was like why stop it stop
lana i want to go home stop hold
yourself together
who's the biggest rom-com fan anna
anna i thought it would be lava that's
what i thought i feel like she watches a
lot of rom-coms
alone by herself i often cry
alone okay yes that's true i do
cry alone but not to rom-coms
i cried because of the general sadness
within
but it's no
i just because of general sadness what
the general sadness within she said
that would be such a good cards against
humanity card
the general sadness with it
whatever move on
me i don't like anything scary i'm not
into like
horror movies or mystery or like
anything so broncos are just always the
best
okay i i've passed you that crown i
think
thank you i've never heard anybody speak
as passionately about rom-coms as again
as anna okay i get so into them and so
attached so
yeah who's most likely to be caught
napping between scenes
ross ross he's a napper
definitely i think so many people in
this cast are nappers lana wouldn't
happen
so yes or not even in the trailer like
we would just come to the green room and
like on the floor under
your chair just like a little robe i've
seen janelle wrap
i've seen janelle robbins i've seen jail
i love a nap
yeah i've seen lana even just like in
her director's chair with like herbie
purchase girl
well you gotta get those naps in when
you can okay
all right noah oh you're gonna say you
dude you're kind of like a bit that i
fall asleep
everywhere really you know that was more
on 13 i think with you guys i
i was more of a friend and didn't and
you know wasn't bored with everyone
else's companionship
unlike dude
it was i i literally sleep consistently
throughout the day
thank you for having us buzzfeed make
sure you
watch to all the boys always and forever
february 12th
on netflix globally and we hope you have
a great day
bye bye goodbye
you